yeah I agree what percent of you would
want to be working moms not me no people
don't know over if your choice was to be
a stay-at-home mom versus a working
mom's dad would anyone here prefer to be
a working mom
um I feel like
because I'm a working mom I feel like
I would I don't know if I'd be
comfortable staying at home all day I
like to be I'm creative so I would like
to maybe have a business or run
something and be in charge of a business
my own earnings basically
um and probably I'd be very bored at
home I know there's a lot to do at home
but it would just be very boring for me
so I would like to have my own business
or be active can I ask your question
why would you prefer to be creative and
be active with someone else's business
rather than be still creative no it
would be my being a mother it'll be my
business
so being a mother yeah I would still be
doing that but I feel like
I would want something else on my own I
don't I wouldn't want to sit at home I
get people like might want that their
husband going out working and just
living off him but at the same time I
would like to have my own I can't I'm
active I can't just sit at home clean it
will get boring but then being a mother
doesn't consist of sitting at home you
have to raise it I'm sure you're very
active I do know that I'm a mum but what
I'm saying is I like to be a mum but
also have something on the side I'm not
saying I'll do it nine to five every
single day or seven days a week but I'm
saying I would like to have something so
whether it's three days a week or if
that's based on the experience that you
want swimming in the back like as a
backup because no it's not backup it's
just my preference I like to be doing
something I agree wouldn't you rather be
making money wouldn't you rather do the
creative stuff with your kids yeah we'll
do that too no you can't do everything
yeah no but you can you can do as much
as you you desire to do so like I could
no from my own experiences I worked I
worked two jobs at one time I still
looked after my child still looked at
her activities who watched the kid when
you're at work
um or she went to school and then I had
um her or her dad at the time but and
what I'm saying is um it depends but if
when he finished work it all rotates
what I'm saying is personally staying at
home maybe five days a week and then two
days I'm doing something of my own like
creative with my daughter or showing her
something like I like Fashions or
something like that or selling something
just just something to keep me active I
think when you're working like I work a
lot and yeah I take responsibility and I
believe that my child misses out a lot
because I work so much and I just think
I just that's all I want to say really I
just think it there's no way you can do
both like I'm aware that my child misses
out and I wouldn't choose this I will
say I wouldn't choose it I take
responsibility for the poor choices that
I've made and I'm accountable but I just
think if I had a choice yeah if I could
rewind and I'm younger and I make a
better decision then I probably would
make a better decision but obviously I
take responsibility so you could ask a
question you would stay at home every
single day I love the idea of staying at
home I'm very home orientated but I have
to take responsibility for the poor
choice that I made and I'm accountable
but if I had a choice rewinding time
which is what everyone would say I'd say
in this circumstance is well most people
I'm sure I don't know but I just that's
my belief anyway what about after the
because obviously you said that you had
your child fairly Young
um can't you do the creative stuff
when they're older like at like 16. why
my question would be
um why now why why when the child is is
younger
um why not why now because there's no
better time than now I don't know what
I'm gonna I might want to be doing just
something different so do you believe
that you can work and develop your whole
time to your child you can't work do you
believe your child's missing out when
you're fulfilling yourself your business
because I'm going to take this once with
it and say my child definitely misses
out my well my business is not like it
doesn't require me to be present and
mine is even mine is and I work from
home and I just hate the fact that I
have to be I feel like yeah I work now I
work around my child because I'm
fortunate enough to do that so she's
missing out then she's not missing out
anymore because I'm more present now
whereas before in the beginning
I'm just saying working from home is
work nobody same as being in an office
your child okay it's not getting your
attention Okay so I work
um I have a business I'm so fashion
business okay um and I also work with my
family so my family owned a children's
home so it's very flexible so I choose
my working hours I can work when my
daughter do I yeah my child don't go to
school and I still believe that she
misses out okay but personally I also
okay so you're saying that she misses
out however there is a percent when
you're a single mom your child is going
to miss out however I I make sure that I
give she does gymnastics swimming done
and I take her to everything so I'm not
only that we go on holidays so we I know
that she's gonna miss out but at the
same time I fill in the spaces so when
she's on half term I take off work I'm
with her every single day so I can't be
Superwoman however I know that she's
going to miss out on certain days
because I'm not present however I'm able
to take off days and be with her and do
extra stuff holidays activities she
doesn't miss out any of that however if
I'm going to work she's going to miss
out on something it's it's not even if
it was the other way around her dad
she's gonna miss it you prefer to work
then be at home with you I prefer to
work to play I can provide for her what
am I what do I want her to do just just
look at the TV I'm saying is a man was
providing for you and you was at home
and you had a choice can you you said
you I refer to work still I would still
prefer to do something yeah because I'm
active I don't I couldn't just sit at
home even though no one said parenting
is sitting at home it's no but what I'm
saying to you is I couldn't just be at
home drawing pictures of my daughter
like we do that anyway but I couldn't do
that every single day it just wouldn't
fulfill me cooking with them you know
yeah like from scratch yeah Auntie Jenny
will bring the kids over and they'll
just like cook from scratch yeah see my
daughter there's so much stuff me and my
daughter we do so much however I
couldn't do that every single day it's
just not me some women that's them it's
interesting so you said it would you
would get bored right yeah why do we
never hear men talk about getting bored
well getting bored because they're not
are they at home every day with their
children four to four days a week a lot
of them are not the majority of them I
feel like we just never really hear men
talk about getting bored in a
relationship or getting bored at home
even when they're single fathers yeah I
get bored very easily I like I feel like
I'm someone that has to be continuously
doing something let's definitely get
bored that's right you can get bored of
being a model and that's what you're
naturally supposed to no I'm not saying
I get bored of being a mother get bored
of the routine I get your point you want
your own identity and your own self it's
not even that I just want to be able to
I just don't want to be saying okay wake
up at six yeah I'm having a child at
home I don't think having children is
like you how could you get bored of
having your children I'm not saying
you're not you're missing to everyone
I'm saying I'm not saying I'm getting
bored of having my children I'll get
bored what do you need to get away you
don't have to do the same thing with me
yeah but who said you have to make it
the same parenting is not the same okay
maybe because of the lifestyle that I
live so the job that I do is no days the
same so nothing is the same whereas if
you're staying at home I feel like it'll
just be it just wouldn't suit me and
that's how you define a home life then I
suppose but for me it just wouldn't what
I imagine for a stay-at-home mom wake up
every day look after your children cook
clean provide that's what I'm imagining
that though so what is it is that even
when you've got that high value man
that's providing everything or is that
if he's just earning a like less than
that well I didn't actually think of it
yeah but that's the first thing that
came because maybe that's what it is
because I feel like if you you had that
option of to sit at home and your
husband's working and you're looked
after I don't think you would want to do
that maybe I don't know because I'm
quite business-minded I would still want
to run something I'm very busy I've run
businesses since I was like yeah but me
and you are different I'm just saying
yeah but I would still say I think it's
I'm very ambitious but when my mum was
at home like I don't want to do nothing
I just want to be with my child like all
day I want to spend as much time as I
can my man looks after me and like if my
man's ambitious like me which he was
like I just want to support what he's
doing to get it I want anything to do
better yeah so like all my energy then
just go into my mind because like we can
build together as a family and you're
building a youth then what would you
have for yourself yeah that's my family
that's everything yeah let's see she
values her kind of success yeah her
career she wants like a modern mindset
because it's me before the family where
she's saying she's saying it's a family
before I put family first family for me
if you know people who knows me I'm very
big on family I'm very familiar this is
my cousin sitting beside me we're very
together but I'm asking you a question
that that and you're saying I would
rather do something for me versus the
family no I'm not saying that I would
say no because because we asked if you
would choose to work what I said it
wouldn't be working if you had the
option to be with your family versus
versus a job but what I'm saying was oh
you're busy it would be a business that
doesn't require much of me so I could
still be like today
no there is possible to set up something
and it doesn't have to I don't have to
be present I've got businesses like that
I work from home do they work once and I
never have to touch it again but but
there's always that element and I could
sit and ask my child which I do
sometimes I talk to her would you prefer
Mommy to be like this because yeah we
should wish you could put the laptop
down I wish you could do this because
all she sees at home is me working but
that's the role I have to live by but
that's not that's now that's not what
I'm saying what I'm saying to you is
there's um know where you can have a
business without putting any time if
that was easy we'd all have money I
wouldn't have to worry about nothing
saying about putting any time in it but
I would reduce my time because I would
understand that I must I reduce my time
I've cut my hours to spend more time
okay but I'm talking about in that sense
so you said I will stay at home I would
make sure that okay two days a week I
would devote to my business and the rest
I'll be at home looking after my child
that is just my preference I can't
imagine and yeah so you value your
career more than you know I value I
value my family a lot I also think it's
important I think we're forgetting that
it's about 30 percent of the time almost
pardon me that's 30 of the time you
would devote to the work two days a week
28.5
I would do I would do two days a week
and that would be satisfying for me
she's at school but and also she would
be at school so she wouldn't actually be
missing out much because she's at school
but but the whole point is a more
traditional mindset it would be to stay
at the family when you look up the
definition of a modern mindset versus
traditional mindset traditional mindset
is the family before me or modern is me
before the family and your answer is
I don't even send my child to school
because I don't get when moms say can't
wait for the kids to go back to school
kicking them out like I do not
understand that so how was your child if
you don't mind my daughter's eight she's
not going to school like how does she do
you homeschool her a homeschooler but I
just I want I want my child to be a
reflection of my family upbringing I
don't want anyone else's input like I
don't I don't understand why someone
would couldn't wait to get the kids for
eight hours a day actually walking in
school is not I don't send my childhood
because I don't want to be around them I
feel like it's good for their upbringing
yeah I understand everyone's got their
own preference but I don't get it but I
can't I can't get my head around maybe
the way I answered it came across that
our family is me before family no
because it does come across like that
okay but it comes across overall overall
it would be I'll be spending more time
with my family because the type of
business I'm thinking of my daughter can
come with me we can I can show her the
way I can show you but they still miss
out because they get a level of business
I understand there's advantages as well
in terms of business but they're missing
out on childhood because my daughter's
more business orientated than a normal
person she's very mature for her age
Michael isn't she's six and she's not
mine is
yeah but I also feel like it's important
to show kids like a good work ethic like
mummy Works she makes money but that's
if you want your children to be that way
when they're older like that's kind of
awesome no I want my daughter to look at
me and be like mum's success
your value in Korea over family because
you want your children to be career you
said you don't want your child to miss
out on her childhood but she's not going
to school so like where does she like
interact with other children she
interacts with her children she got
family she got cousins because of her
family no and she goes to groups in
classes my whole point isn't if it's
right or wrong I'm saying that's a
modern mindset like your answer is a
modern mindset
perception I'm not saying but long term
it's it's all based on your child or
your children having better careers it's
all bad no it's not based on a better
interest for me it's giving myself not
based on love or building and things
like it's all based on it's all
basically what do you mean sorry it's
based on my team so you're saying me
having a business is uh wanting to have
a business as long-sized the reason you
want a career is for a better outcome
outcome financially and I've still you
want a better life but if I'm staying at
home at that point I'm already there
okay what I'm saying what do you what do
you want the business for like what is
it more active Okay okay okay wait wait
wait this is this is the point me yeah
your answer me yeah to keep me active
that's my point it's a modern mindset
I'm not saying if it's writer it's wrong
so what you're saying know thyself it's
just that that's a modern mindset but
then at the same time as long as I'm
keeping myself active if I can't keep
myself active how am I going to be able
to this is my opinion how would I be
able to sustain that home and make it
happy and cook and clean if I has been
active got to do with going to work
that's my own no no no there's nobody
but if you are saying that
first of all my business is creative I'm
not only creative so why do you run a
business why do I run a business because
I have a passion would you do it for
free you let me finish
um the business I run is not just a
business for financial gain because I
give a lot back you let me finish I put
on events and I also do it to inspire
and single mothers and people like me
and people are not like me so it's not
just to read the whole she's right it's
not a business if you're not making
money but the thing is I am making money
but at the same time
it's not just for me living I'm not
living off this business because I work
at the same time this is a business that
I've put on it's not a business then if
it's not about money let me finish I
didn't say it it's a passion project
it's a passion process
because business is profit okay but
there's the thing is I get profit I'm
not living off that profit I think
you've been in denial because I own a
business I run a business and I'm very
passionate about what I do like there's
been times I've done it can I just
answer your point you're saying to me
that the business I would want to do is
based on finances and based on profit
but if that was the case I wouldn't work
I would just totally agree my business
is profit I'm saying yeah if you're
doing business for any other needs other
than profit it's not a business it's a
hobby okay can you go back to the point
where you said it's not it's based
something about not love it's based on
you said something else I was on about
family unit like I don't know you've
gone to back too which is basically
saying is you're more focused on
maintaining your child rather than
raising your child no because my child
is it's not about that it's not about
maintaining what I realize as a mother
and from Life Experiences you have to be
you actually have to put your mind first
your mental health first you cannot
raise a child in the best way possible
if you're not mentoring in the right
society as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible